[Música]
olá a todos votar
obrigado por este convite da imagem e é
precisamente a imagem que eu estava a
falar convosco e pensando no tema que
tem este evento a nossa voz ainda
continue um pouco mais de forma que
podia falar da imagem
mas não aprovar hoje em dia é a forma de
comunicação que temos mais forte é
precisamente a nível visual
portanto acho que o que nós podemos
pensar é na forma de falar sobre a nossa
voz visual e fotografia certeza que é um
instrumento que todos vocês utilizam
nosso dia a dia e uma ferramenta super
importante para a forma como vai ser se
exprimem mas a fotografia nem sempre foi
um processo simples de fazer e após a
invenção da fotografia apenas aquilo que
aprendi uma técnica que é bastante
complicada é podiam fazer as imagens no
entanto algumas décadas depois da
invenção da fotografia uma marca que
todos nós conhecemos permitiu que este
processo fosse muito mais simples e
acessível a toda a gente
nós encontramos é uma democratização da
imagem tem acesso a câmeras fotográficas
fazer as suas próprias imagens e de
certa forma é ter uma ligação direta com
fotografia
todos têm os nossos álbuns digitais e
falando com o tempo atual é
provavelmente os álbuns são pastas
cheias de imagens obtidas em
computadores
pois ainda se lembram como funcionava há
bem pouco tempo atrás nós fazemos os
nossos álbuns e as fotografias serviram
para recordar e eram escolhidas nós
fazíamos calhar não tanta certeza que
não tantas
não fazemos tantas imagens e
utilizávamos essas imagens de um gênero
do livro para para recordar os momentos
que mais gostávamos que era o mais
importante para nós e assim dessa forma
que fazíamos era construir as nossas
memórias e nem sempre o nosso álbum
fotográfico ficava apenas neste neste
formato
muitas vezes e ainda ter certeza que
vocês conhecem já entraram em casas onde
o álbum e as memórias estão distribuídas
pela casa seja com os peritos seja pelas
imagens que estão nas mesas nas compras
e tenho a certeza que todos vocês já
entraram numa casa de festas já viram
nem que seja quando eram crianças
alguns que a bolsa família tinha dos
eventos mais importante hoje em dia essa
emoção com imagens já não é tanto assim
os álbuns deixam de ser na maior parte
das vezes em livros passam a ser os
nossos telemóveis nossos computadores e
essa transição para a imagem digital ela
por transformar completamente os nossos
hábitos com a imagem
a bits que chegam é ser um pouco
exagerados e de certeza que todos vocês
têm a perceção da quantidade de imagens
que são produzidas atualmente
portanto para ter um nível de uma
obsessão que tem mais clara de como
funciona a imagem nos dias de hoje
acho que é mais fácil olhar para os
números e pensar como é que a imagem foi
ruim na última década pouco tempo
no ano 2000 no final do ano
falávamos numa produção que chegava a 80
milhões de imagens no entanto dez anos
depois este valor já tinha aumentado
para 240 vez que este ano o número de
imagens produzidas ultrapassa o trillian
acho que este número é imenso é um
número exagerado a mente grande um pouco
alarmante para a produção que nós
fizemos da imagem
a minha questão é será que nós estamos a
ter noção da forma como utilizamos a
imagem fotográfica e das consequências
que podem advir disso esta produção
exagerada de imagens pode estragar a
nossa capacidade de questionar as
imagens e saber de que forma é que
estamos a entregar as nossas próprias
memórias
se por um lado os álbuns que faziam tá
bem pouco tempo atrás serviam para
construir as nossas marias
hoje em dia o que está a acontecer é que
a imagem está a provocar com que nós
tínhamos problemas a em guardar memórias
porque atualmente o que nós fazemos é
fotografar manhã à noite tudo aquilo que
nos rodeia
já não estamos a construir as nossas
memórias não estamos a construir o nosso
presente e isso pode alterar muito a
pressão que temos das coisas
e pior ainda criar uma superfície levado
no momento de fazer as imagens quem
ainda não fez uma fotografia hoje
quem é que já fez uma fotografia ganhou
está um exemplo de um trabalho de um
artista tentou exemplo ficar exatamente
esta situação
o artista que são em 2011 fez esse
trabalho era muito simples o que eu
queria mostrar era esta esse exagero de
produção de imagens
o trabalho acontece com este esta forma
de encher um espaço de exposição que o
artista faz é é apenas 24 horas
faz impressão de todas as imagens que
são colocadas na internet
as plataformas do google do flickr e no
facebook apenas um dia
imagens imagens todas que são colocadas
na internet apenas onde a ultrapassam um
milhão de imagens está apenas num dia é
número exageradamente grandes portanto o
meu trabalho enquanto fotógrafo enquanto
investigador a nível da comunicação
visual fazem questionar todos estes
hábitos sociais começam a ser notados
atualmente a nível da imagem e essas
formas de utilizar a imagem maneira
oficial mas não só
nós estamos aqui a falar da nossa voz
ser uma das ferramentas de comunicação
mais forte imagem
então nós vamos ter muita atenção aquilo
que fazemos quando publicamos imagens ou
quando produzimos imagens essas formas
de produzir imagens selecionar imagens e
e e pensar as imagens fazem parte também
da nossa da nossa responsabilidade
na comunicação que nós fazemos em nosso
mundo
um dos exemplos que podem mostrar esta
este poder que a imagem pode ter pessoas
a não tanto tempo assim na história
recente
após a revolução de outubro na rússia em
uma geração de jovens após um período de
evolução silva que a sociedade tem que
ser ao travar se a imagem vai ser
utilizada quanto na sua força é a imagem
vai ser utilizada com todas as
estratégias possíveis para melhorar o
mundo para apresentar a vida moderna e
mudar a sociedade
as intenções eram todas boas e criam
cada imagem de qualquer forma para
promover essa cultura e desenvolvimento
no entanto a imagem pode ter um poder
muito forte mas a parte desse poder
também existam trigo muito muito grande
neste exemplo vamos ver o que acontece
outras décadas mais tarde quando os
regimes totalitaristas se puseram do
mundo e se transforma num mundo numa
segunda guerra mundial e adotam
exatamente as mesmas estratégias para
dizer o oposto e para promover conflito
e óbvio que nós devemos pensar em um
declive vemos e vivemos também pensar
que estamos num mundo em que os
conflitos são cada vez mais crescentes
estamos a viver atualmente numa europa
que está em colapso
portanto é a forma como nós usamos a
imagem tem algo responsabilidades
queremos uma mudança na forma como
olhamos e questionamos a imagem
extremamente importante e temos que
pressionar constantemente a imagem ea
minha dúvida é se vai ser este ano uma
imagem vem todos os dias nós somos
constantemente bombardeados com imagens
desde manhã até à noite sejam imagens na
televisão nos telejornais no próprio
jornal
imagens de publicidade e as imagens que
vocês vendas nas redes sociais os vossos
amigos
e eles imagens que vocês fazem também
portanto forma que você acha questionam
todas estas imagens forma que vocês usam
de uma maneira menos superficial
alguns estudos atuais têm até
demonstrava que o uso das imagens que
nós fazemos na contemporaneidade estão
estão ajudar novos problemas que nem
sequer falávamos antes
além de que os problemas de memória
jogos desportista este exagero de
imagens também e todos vocês sabem os
problemas que são causados a nível
social a nível pessoal uma grande crise
de representação começar a existir e que
está muito ligada também uma crise de
identidade podem existir com excesso de
representação que fazemos todos nós
fazemos autorretratos agora chamados
elfes todos nós temos uma forma de criar
uma imagem daquilo que queremos para nós
mas que muitas vezes não têm a ver com o
que eu realmente somos
essa ilusão e essa forma de querer
mostrar algo mas sem pensar naquilo que
somos possa criar um conflito muito
grande e pode criar uma série de
frustrações quando quando os
confrontamos com aquela imagem que
fazemos nós
nesta desta investigação sobre a imagem
nesta pesquisa que eu pretendo fazer
numa altura em que estava como você
terminar os meus estudos superiores
tinha essa vontade de conhecer mais
mas a verdade é que como muitas pessoas
que acabam ensino superior
o que acontece é que para um com um
mercado de trabalho precário
as oportunidades são muito poucas já que
muitas vezes as pessoas desmoralizam
quando querem fazer muito e vem com a
possibilidade de enfrentar fazer coisas
é minha intenção em compreender o mundo
surgiu a partir desta desta é análise da
imagem ea partir da imagem eu queria
compreender de que forma é que
funcionava tudo com criava vai querer
fazer um projeto sem saber bem o que
aqui se aplicáveis em saber vai
responsabilizar o trabalho estado 60 é
construir um projeto mais uma vez que
não tinha muitas outras alternativas
porque também nas áreas das imagens há
uma dificuldade grande atualmente um
mundo em constante de encontrar uma
certeza é a nível de trabalho o que
acontece a seguir criar um arquivo para
mim foi mais do que uma escola e que me
ensinou que continua a ensinar muito até
hoje
claro que é muito difícil sem
financiamento sem apoios começar um
projeto mas a minha experiência que eu
posso dizer é que o conhecimento nunca
vai ser
nunca deve ser prejudicado quando o
quanto queremos compreender alguma coisa
ainda que estejamos no mundo não não
seja onde não seja fácil iniciar
projetos e onde facilmente podemos mudar
desmoralizar a intenção é que nunca se
esqueçam do objetivo no local começaram
o projeto e neste caso quando comecei o
arquivo o que eu queria era criar uma
fila de pessoas que tal como eu queria
conhecer mais e criam entender o mundo a
partir da imagem
o que acontece é que tal como também
possibilidades que temos a nível digital
ea nível da internet cada vez mais a
proximidade com outras pessoas é
facilitava então a minha ideia era criar
uma vez maior de profissionais e do e
iniciantes nesta área pretender sem
partilhar ideias que tenderá sempre
partilhar conhecimentos e novas
propostas eo arquivo é isso mesmo com
uma série de publicações foi tentado
fazer e fui fazendo a partir de 2011
partilhando ensaios e entrevistas e uma
plataforma onde ver todos esses
conteúdos e uma série de trabalhos que
vão sendo sempre atualizados
novas propostas visuais
tudo isto pode parecer complicado e
fazer projetos que a partida não mostra
uma uma distribuição rápida pode ser
desmoralizante
mas temos que nos adaptar às condições
que existem neste caso o que acontece é
que nos movermos preço em três
temos e que não podemos deixar apagar
com consistência com entre a
simplificação retribuição pode parecer a
pescar
após seis anos que estava a trabalhar
com muita dedicação neste projecto
embora soe estranho sempre sempre com o
máximo de três
este projeto agora é minha tese
investigação com um com uma bolsa de
estudos completa
portanto mas chega mais tarde passei até
vão receber uma retribuição de uma forma
que nem sequer imaginavam como é que
podia existir
e eu quando comecei este projeto porque
eu queria aprender mais e nunca imaginei
que hoje ea chegar a uma tese de
investigação em que estão a pagar para
fazer o que eu gosto
portanto não se esqueçam ainda cada vez
mais para fazer alguma coisa que seja
útil e para fazer alguma coisa que possa
mexer tem que contar com um grupo de
pessoas têm que acreditar no governo
joaquim e distribuição de trabalho e
levado juntar mais pessoas para nos
ajudarem a fazer aquilo que vocês gostam
e nada disso seria possível se não
tivesse uma equipa de voluntários
durante anos tem ajudado a desenvolver
todo este projecto a desenvolver a nível
do design das traduções e com a mesma
dedicação permitem que o projeto possa
ter uma imagem e uma qualidade da
apresentação
portanto quando voltamos a falar do tema
da nossa voz não se esqueçam que a nossa
voz também é visual e todas as imagens
que nós fizemos tem uma conseqüência
e final deixamos de dar importância às
imagens vemos diariamente as imagens de
notícias
as imagens que representam o mundo para
pensar numa representação que pode ser
mais superficial comuns entrado apenas
para nós não estamos a levar a
importância que a imagem 10
não estamos a respeitar o poder e também
como vimos o perigo que a imagem possa
ter
portanto em vez de usar a imagem com
mandatos ou como como a superficialidade
talvez seja altura de todos juntos
fazemos uma mudança é a partir das
nossas práticas
mesmo as mais simples que podemos
melhorar este mundo
[Aplausos]